now welcome to this video blitz game
against Leon 28 this Venezuela Colombia
hmm ok check ok at least I got the
general region right ok bo go with a 5
let's see you're going to play know the
main line with g 33 c 2 yeah probably i
can just play the same setup with you
five yeah it looks like we're going to a
transpose ok usually black tries to play
Bishop c5 and keep the bishop but I can
think I can I can't first castle here
see what he's doing yeah first texts e4
pawn yeah this is them set up that black
is aiming for in this slide should I
play Bishop c5 i'm not sure but how does
see what exactly is he playing against
that we should see one maybe yeah Bishop
see one ok but night a4 I can always
play Bishop Asaph this isn't this isn't
a problem really so
do i do I develop this Bishop somewhere
g 4 h 5 g six men don't know it doesn't
doesn't seem right to me ok I think ice
need to protect p7 to make this Bishop
mobile in Bishop d7 would be would be
useful oh yeah Bishop d7 would be useful
hmm yeah wow talk about an embarrassing
moment really oh gate yeah I get some
gate Jim deserve this looks ugly ok so
let's see how to how to keep this going
yes momma Dean was clear that this was
coming anyway I was somehow I needed to
play b6 Bishop d7 and ok so he's some
how does he continue or maybe maybe I
can go here exchange the night and then
play Bishop e7 ok Queen takes I guess
okay can he can play Bishop e3 but there
should be three mm-hm
yeah all that one simply I thought Queen
f5s may be okay yeah it's ugly but then
let's try to to defend it's not much fun
but then maybe it's still a position you
can fight just go here the Queen deform
I can take g two down now maybe this
isn't so terrible yeah but this is is an
ugly move maybe you form coming back
down still yes oops yes we can test
position quite a bit
okay d 5 55 is probably just going to
take f6 and TD 5 okay i need to also
secure the King against background bank
back rank issues let's see Bishop c4
doesn't really help
I take you for and I thought I could
take a form of course but maybe I cannot
you can play at five then I'm in a self
been very ugly
it doesn't get any better not not really
and they have loose pieces c6 is not
covered a seven is unprotected hmm sorry
yeah you have it okay we can take f six
seven maybe yeah this doesn't even feel
like the most dangerous thing and it
looks pretty bad you can okay I can take
before maybe play would be to this isn't
so bad no let's not bad at all hmm
yeah yes sir really miss plate that I
think I'm in excellent shape now
yeah there's no made quite resigned yeah
i guess i'm here at the same thing here
that happens to me quite often a few if
your opponent is playing complete
complete crap you relax too much until I
really had a terrible position they
completely misplayed everything and TM
freakin win many moves I guess computer
points out here e 5 plus 7 plus 7 s is
enough the ideas to play that and now
it's made threat on yet yeah completely
busted many ways but this this felt less
dangerous in comparison still white
should win but it's not not that let
clear and here and I know it's already a
bit tricky yeah computer is going down
to two calling this equal the ship c1
some books e1 is the move that is giving
after that i'm already winning out yeah
I am so he has got no way to stop the
beep on yeah okay this is giving giving
the queen but they're already I was no
move on this i have f just before I'm
promote I'm not made here but I can
always go to age 70 on the check yeah
very lucky win he completely outplayed
me him it all started with this
nonsensical rugby aid this is a rather
normal position the thing is I need to
have Bishop b8 in this kind of
line and forgot about that let's say
let's say I play em just to show Ruby
aid was really bad here if I play am a
little improving moves like that for
example if he plays in the same manner i
can drop back to be aight i know that
this looks a bit strange but our play a
c6 soon to kick out the snide and it's
not a problem at all the other issue is
that maybe after look the one I
shouldn't play Bishop c5 immediately
it's not a bad move but I can think
about other continuations maybe Ruby ATM
hard to say alright thanks for watching